hey Luke here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and this is my forging
setup and I've done a lot of projects
and videos with this Forge I built an
african spear japanese pocket knife
couple axes so i get a lot of questions
from people who are interested in having
something similar so if you want a
really cheap forge setup this is the
video for you I'm going to show you
exactly how to do it so this is an old
video I posted on my other YouTube
channel the catfish and carp YouTube
channel so I reacted it and just cleaned
it up a little bit added a little bit of
extra footage and here you go here's how
to build a fort on a budget
all right so let me give you kind of a
rundown of what I'm gonna be building
let me show you the design now this
furnace is a wood-burning furnace it
runs off of charcoal or wood scraps you
can also use coal if you want and it is
powered by a shop vac so the shop vac is
blowing air into the furnace you can
also use a hairdryer you could use a
hand
blower specialty blacksmithing blowers
but this is what I had around the house
and it works really good let me give you
a little example here
now I'm using lumber scraps in wood but
if you use coal I hear that it gets even
hotter and it works a little bit better
you don't have to stoke it as often and
it burns a little bit hotter so if you
can source coal and use that instead
that's a great option the great thing
about these wood-burning forges is you
can use just about anything to make them
I use sheet steel here but you know I
could have used this helium canister cut
it in two and use it you can use the a
BBQ shell you can you could use a metal
trash can probably I mean in just about
anything will work if you insulate it
well enough the thing is is that sand is
a fabulous insulator and so as long as
you have a good layer of sand on top of
the steel and the fires high up you
shouldn't have any problem there is
almost zero heat being transferred down
so as long as the fire rides high up on
the furnace the metal doesn't get heated
up this is cold okay
everything but the very rim of the metal
is cold to the touch and then you
basically have some sort of base to put
it on and I've got a frame made out of
two by fours and I've got a little work
area here with a vise okay so the first
step in my Forge project is I'm going to
put holes in this pipe now this is a
two-inch heavy gauge black steel pipe
there you go six holes
well I may be the worst welder ever and
this may be the worst welding machine
ever but we actually did it I think this
will actually hold up oh it's so on yeah
I don't even want to show you your
close-up
I'll tell you what that test run works
pretty good it fired right up and a lot
of air going through there even with the
sand covering up the vents it's cold
down here where the sand is any part
that's covered with sand is good you
know it's a little lopsided so this part
is exposed there was no sand and I can
see where it's warped and bent a little
bit I don't think it's causing any
permanent damage to it but I think what
I need to do is once it cools down I
need to level it out and make sure that
the metals not not exposed that all the
metals covered with sand and I think
we're ready to go now I just need to
mount my anvil and we'll go from there I
think this might do the trick
well it's a bit low and it's uneven on
one end so you'd have to term it he's
worried about there
I don't know if I made it better or
worse
half a bubble off one okay for fuel I'm
using charcoal and I've got charcoal
that's just leftover from my fireplace
and from forging the night before and
you can buy or make charcoal comes in
these chunks but you want it big chunky
stuff we want hardwood charcoal or you
can get pieces of wood so just you want
chunks little chunks like this you know
scraps from this and that these old
two-by-four chunks work really well I
like these best just about this length
yeah used up a little more than half the
charcoal and half the pile quite a bit
of fuel of course I'm not very good at
this
and so you know if I had to do it over
again I think I could have done it much
quicker and used but much less fuel but
you know
it's been over a year since I made this
Forge
I've been using it quite heavily and let
me show you how well it's held up and
kind of some of the pros and cons first
off the big thing is I'm using a wooden
base and you can see here there's some
bird marks
we're occasionally hot coals will fall
off the side and get in these cracks and
burn and you can see you can see here
and maybe down here a few places that
it's burned the wood this side not so
bad because usually I'm working on this
side I can see it happen and I could
just brush the coal off so what I've
done to keep that from happening is when
I build a fire I take one log and just
put it right there and I take another
log put it right there and I put my
coals my fire in between and that keeps
coals from spilling over a bigger
problem with this design is that it
Wiggles a lot you can see here there's
quite a bit of play and so when you've
got something in the vise and you're
sawing on it or whatever this thing
shakes and shimmy is quite a bit and the
more shimmies the the looser it gets so
occasionally I have to go through and
put nails back in and since I did this
video I added these cross pieces here
and here and over on this side and down
there to try to give it a little bit
more rigidity and I really need
add some more so if you're doing this
design at home and you want this thing
to hold up well under for many years use
exterior deck screws and add more cross
pieces another thing I have done
differently is in the video you saw me
use sand and gravel to make the forge
wouldn't do that
just gravel don't even monkey with the
sand now let me show you the anvil the
anvil here is held up pretty well for a
$65 anvil it's it's surprisingly soft
steel and so there's little dents in it
and from where you know you miss a good
chunk of these dents are from where I
let the Boy Scouts come and work on my
my anvil and a lot of them just missed
so much that they they just swing as
hard as they could without much accuracy
and so a lot of these dents are from Boy
Scouts but all in all for being a really
cheap set up that I did myself without a
lot of prior experience it's held up
really well to a lot of use I've used
this thing a bunch and I'm pretty proud
of it so it's a design that definitely
can be approved upon and if you have
better materials and better tools and
better skills go for it but this'll work
if you're looking to just get into the
supplier to the Hobby this will do it
thanks for watching we hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you'd like to see
more great videos from the outdoor boys
YouTube channel don't forget to click
Subscribe we put out new videos every
week and don't forget to hit that Bell
button so you'll get notified when we
put out another great video